i'm joined now by lord coe president of
world athletics member of uh
the international olympic committee and
of course chairman of the london 2012
organizing committee and uh former
olympic champion so it goes on uh good
to see you
um uh lord ko so look covet cases rising
no spectators sponsors lying low
a country withdrawing the japanese
broadly against it
is this a games worth going ahead with
yes it is and we we have talked about
that before and i
genuinely think so the systems
and the processes in place they're never
going to be perfect but i think they
will deliver
a safe and secure games both for the
athletes
and also crucially for the communities
that are hosting uh our games and
look you know one of the stats that i've
always found rather sobering is that 70
of the athletes only have one bite at
this particular cherry i was lucky i
went to two games
and i think we were right to do
everything we possibly could
to protect those games and particularly
the ecosystem that is sport we mustn't
overlook the fact that these games
are in large part the revenue
distribution
for many olympic sports that will rely
really heavily on it i do all genuinely
think that when we get into the games
and
the sport really starts in earnest and
track and field is still
you know over a week away i do genuinely
think
people will focus more on the sport and
less on
some of the challenges around them yeah
but i mean but the olympics are about
great sport yes
but it's also about the community and
legacy and about
the participation of the people in the
host city and none of that
is really going to happen is it
well i i don't know i mean you're right
there aren't going to be fans in the
stadium and there aren't any overseas
visitors
but this doesn't stop the games being a
you know a manifestation of legacy and i
know
from the organizing committee and all
the municipal authorities
in tokyo that they have very big legacy
plans
even off the back of the games that are
by no means
usual and you know legacy comes in many
many different ways many many different
forms
but japan i know wants these games to be
successful
and look i think we probably and i think
we have to concede here i think we've
done
a pretty good job i'm on the evaluation
commission i
work closely with the organizing
committee i think they've done a pretty
good job in explaining the processes and
the protocols to the athletes
the uh the media the technical officials
and
and certainly the federations i think
probably
uh there is a gap of understanding about
the thousands of hours that have
cumulatively taken place in order to
make these games
as safe and as secure as possible maybe
local communities
are not as aware as they should be
of what has been done yeah
to protect them yeah but there are
already cases i mean what about the fear
of the athletes because
i mean they will be fearing getting a
sort of
positive test just before their their
case
um their their race rather fear of the
locals about you know the olympics being
a super spreader it's going to be a very
diff different olympics isn't it and and
for the athletes
let's let's face it a pretty grim one
really as an experience
mark we should accept that and accept
that no i don't think they're going to
be grim for the athletes i think the
athletes and i speak to them all the
time it's my job
they are very very keen to be there they
understand the scriptures they
understand the frustrations but they
also know
as i've said earlier 70 of them don't
get this chance again
and they want to take it and all the
other delivery partners the media
particularly are obviously very keen to
be there
and and i do make this point broadly
that you know we shouldn't be coy or
naive about the
financial uh realism around these games
you know the broadcast revenue that is
derived from
in large part keeps olympic sports
afloat 90
of it goes back into those programs to
identify athletes and all the legacy
uh that we want to see so this is
too big to cancel isn't it too big to
cancel
it well you it it would have been a
cancellation i've heard people talk
about well couldn't we postponed it for
another year or so no
the answer is that if you were going to
postpone that's a cancellation because
the matrix that forms all the events you
know we've moved our world championships
one year down the track that now
collides with the commonwealth games
european championships you're into
uh a beijing uh winter games you're into
a world cup
so we would if there there was never a
question about
postponement again it would have been a
cancellation and we would have gone
through to 24
for paris and i think that the
importance of having these games
and look you know maybe we're being
slightly
judged on a different set of metrics
here i've like
most people in in the uk around europe
we've gloried in
the european football championships
we've seen full stadia
uh wimbledon was stuffed to the gunnels
do you think there should be
spectators at the olympics do you think
there should be they should have allowed
something
that's a decision that has to be made on
the ground and you have to respect local
health authorities you have to expect
you have to accept government you know
decisions around that that's not for us
to second guess
of course i would have preferred to have
seen noisy passionate fans there i think
some of the events will not be as you
know as as
bullies as they would have been the
athletes i have to say have responded
remarkably well we've seen in track and
field we've obviously seen no diminution
to their performances
of late but let me just pick up another
point you made
don't run away with the idea that
suddenly ten and a half thousand
competitors are all descending on tokyo
they're not they're going from
the airport to the village they are
going to be tested on a daily basis
there are no
there's no sightseeing and no karaoke
bars there's no wandering
around the city they're going to be
there for only a few days beforehand
depending upon how they progress through
their competitions
um whether they get through to a medal
round or they're bombed out in the first
round
they're going to be leaving very shortly
after okay so i think
that given the processes given the
protocols in
an inordinately complex situation i
think the organizing committee has done
a pretty good job
and i do think that when we get into the
sport we will be focusing on that
all right look 20 seconds literally you
think dude that once
all the drama and the sport gets
underway the other stuff
can be pushed aside at least temporarily
20 seconds
i'm not saying he's going to be pushed
aside i'm not saying this is another
sort of
twist of the news cycle but look i've
been involved in the delivery of games
i've been
a competitor in games you do see
this you know under these are difficult
circumstances everybody accepts that
but i remember before london people were
focusing on all sorts of things in the
lead up to the games
as soon as sport started okay it
transformed
the landscape and people focused on
perform